[موسيقى]
يمكن بعد 12 سنه حرب كتير صعب انه لا
الناس رجعت على الشوارع
بالاخص نحن كسوريين عنا ارتباط كثير
بالمنازلنا عنا ارتباط في يوم الجمعه
وبجامعات العيله وهي القصص احنا رجعنا
نشوف الناس بالشارع رجعنا نشوفهم ما عندهم
مقاول رجعنا نشوفهم مرضانين وبردانين
وتعبانين وجوعانين
هاي الصور كلها حفله الزعفرتنا بصراحه وما
بعرف اذا ترك التاثير سلبي جواتنا لكن
الشي اللي بخليني راضيه عن حالي انه انا
ضليت هنيك لاخر نفس لاخر نمط
[موسيقى]
نركز الايواء مو كذا عائله عايشه سوا
فكتير صار في
التهابات بوليه بسبب عدم النظافه بسبب
يعني دخول للحمام وما في نظافه لا بالمركز
وفي اكثر من شخص فكتير كنا عم نركز على
شغله توعيه التوعيه عن النظافه كتير حاولت
انه حتى هنيك النساء لما عم يجوا اشخاص
انه الشباب او دكاتره عم يخجلوا من
التعامل معهم بينما لما يكون في مثلا
دكتوره او مثل انا صيدلاني او هاي عم يجوا
بيحكوا باريحيه يعني بالمعاناه تبعهم اكثر
شيء كانوا عم يعانوا من الالتهابات بصراحه
[موسيقى]
كان ما في مرافق ما في مياه مياه مخلطه
الوجود بالاضاءات في في ازدحام بالاوقات
في ناس ما بيعرفون في رجال هن ما بيعرفون
في سائلني ما بيعرفون
معرض النساء تبدا من الدوره الشهريه
احنا طالعين يعني عدم ذلك للاسف الازمات
هاي بتمس خصوصيه المراه بتمس مساحه
الشخصيه بتمس كرامتها احيانا
[موسيقى]
بدايه انا بما اني ام شوف الصبايا كانه
بناتي صراحه
فالبدايه لما قالوا انه بيطلعوا طاقم شباب
وبناته وكذا يعني انا بيني وبين حالي بدون
ما اظهر اشي حسيت انه يا ترى انه بيطلع
بايدهم ابعتهم قصه لهيك امكان كانوا عنده
جداره كتير كبيره انه هن يتحملوا هيك
اعباء وفعلا الصبايا طلعوا واثبتوا ما شاء
الله عنهم يعني قوه على الارض فاقه الحدود
حتى في شغلات بتحس انه بتحملوا اشياء
الضغوطات يمكن محلك اكثر من الشباب ولكن
بطوله بال اكتر بشوي بجوز المراه عندها
بضل هيك شويه صبر وكذا وانسانيتها وحليتها
عاليه بما انه هي انثى بالفطره فبيكون
عندها كثير الدفاع قوي وانه بدي ساعد
[موسيقى]
انه انا حدا هادي رايق لما حطيت على وسط
كارثه وانه عم ساعد وبكل قوتي ما كنت بعرف
انه بصراحه جواتي كلها هي القوه وحتى انه
نوع
تحليلي نوع من الذكاء نوع من استراتيجيات
معينه ما كنت بعرف انه انا بقدر اعمل عن
جد كل هذا لما حطيت بارضو الواقع لا
اكتشفت فيه في شغلات جواتي طلعت بالعكس
كثير مبسوطه بحالي انا عن جد كتير مبسوطه
بدانا بحلب جبله ولاديه كان عنا ثلاث
مراكز بعثنا فرقنا عليهم انا من الاشخاص
اللي طلعتوا عجبني
عملنا مستودعات هنيك وجهزنا متطوعين شي
الحلو كان انه المتطوعين هم كانوا
من الاشخاص المتضررين في منهم اللي تصدعت
بيوتهم في رحلهم اشخاص من اقاربهم للاسف
بهذه الازمه اللي صارت
قررنا بالمستودعات هاي نستقبل الشاحنات
نفرز الاغراض ونجهز سيلر او حصص ننزل فيها
ونشاركها مع اهالينا المتضررين مشاركه
الصبايا اللي بعمري وحتى اصغار هذا الشيء
بياثر على المجتمع ككل لانه بشوف حتى
التربيه بكره لما بتربي اطفال راح تربيه م
على العطاء بغض النظر ان كانت بنت او شب
الاثنين فعالين بالمجتمع والاثنين لازم
يكون لهم مسؤوليه بهذا الوضع الكارسي لانه
هذا وضع انساني ما في شيء اصعب من انه
الشخص يخسر البيت فنحن
كان واجبي انا
كيندا انه شاركهم لهذول الناس بالشيء اللي
بقدر شارك فيه وجودي معهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان في طفله صغيره اسمها مريانا سلمناها
هنيك فرز علب صغيره للاطفال سكاكر وعصير
فمريانا اول شي هالدنيا هاي الاسواره هيك
تعبير عنها شكرا لالنا وهي اصغر مستواها
صارت هنيك فاجئتني مره عم اقول لها انه
خذي لالك علبه يعني من هدول اللي عم
تعمليهم فهيك بكل ثقه قالت لي لا غيري او
لا في اطفال هناك بيحتاجوها اكثر من